well thank you it's a the mic is on I
can tell it's a too loud it's okay so
it's a pleasure for me to be here this
is a particular challenge I'm used to
speaking but not to such a diverse group
so I've prepared I feel confident but if
I don't get it right you can interrupt
me and and ask questions in fact I
encourage you to do that and I'll give
you some opportunities to ask questions
as we go so I'm going to talk about what
some of what biomedical engineers do and
I'm going to focus on things that we've
done in my research lab here and and
obviously it's a big field so only be
talking about a small part of it but and
I given myself a title which I couldn't
possibly live up to medicines of the
future that's a big that's a big topic
so I'll say a little bit about what I
think what I think medicines of the
future will look like some of them are
actually medicines that are now being
used today but we're going to be
delivering them in different ways and
they're going to be useful for treating
diseases that we have difficulty
treating now so that's that's my topic
and as professors Elm mentioned I I grew
up in Iowa and I know there's a couple
of people in the room but hopefully most
of you know where Iowa is it's going to
start off as a geography lesson if if
not so I always here I I grew up here
and for some reason which I can't
explain now I was always interested in
math and chemistry and start science in
general but math and chemistry in
particular and it didn't come from my
family my grandparents were all farmers
this is what Iowa looks like not
everywhere but in many many places this
is my grandfather's farm which was
actually his grandfather's farm in in
the very southern tier of counties
Ringgold County Iowa and a lot of
science happens in places like this so
maybe that's where I got exposed to
interest in natural phenomenon and how
to make things work but it's it's a long
way from that to hear
and I'm not going to say very much about
the story I'd be happy to answer
questions about how how I got here if
you if you like at the end but if you
would have told me when I was a middle
school student or a high school student
that idea scientist and that I'd be
teaching at a place like Yale I you
might as well have told me I was going
to win the lottery and it I just didn't
think it would happen it wasn't
something imaginable so I'm happy to be
here talking to you about about what we
do and feel very fortunate to be in this
position so I encourage all of you who
haven't started your careers yet to be
open to whatever happens you don't know
remarkable things can happen to you
particularly if you pay attention to
math and science just as further
background these are the courses that I
teach at Yale to sort of give you an
idea of what what I've come to to be an
expert in I teach an introductory course
in biomedical engineering and I saw
Durga here earlier a Yale student who
took the course there she is she was one
of the students giving you
demonstrations so this is to introduce
people to the field and I'm going to
give you a little introduction to it
today i teach physiological systems and
this might be seem strange to you that
that an engineer is is teaching human
physiology to future doctors and but but
really we understand physiology so well
now we understand how all of our organs
are built that one can understand them
in terms of the mechanisms by which they
work and it's really engineers who who
who can sort of synthesize the
information that biologists have and
understand how to present it I think so
that's how I ended up there I teach a
course in drug delivery and design which
all which is the topic i'll be talking
about and i'm very interested in how to
do things in the brain and that will
become clear as we go so this is sort of
the outline for what i want to talk
about new ways for giving medicines new
ways for giving drugs to make them more
effective and in particular to make them
safer one of the biggest problems we
have when we develop Metis
to treat diseases this is particularly
true for diseases of the brain one of
the biggest problems we have is that
they cause side effects in other places
that that that often are worse than the
disease you're trying to treat and so
how could you take medicines that you
know work well and give them to people
so that they don't cause these side
effects so I'm going to talk about that
in the context of treating cancer which
you all know is a is a is a terrible set
of diseases that we still don't
understand completely and we still don't
know how to treat and then I'm going to
talk about something that I think is
even more forward-looking the idea that
one could use molecules to cause tissues
to regenerate in people that one could
put chemical systems together in ways
that allow you to build new tissue in
tissues like in the brain or in the
heart that are that are that are failing
okay so this is the brain who knows
which is the front where's the forehead
here do you know which which side this
one or this one yeah this is the this is
the front of it I should be pointing to
this one right this is the big one but
that's the one I see best this is the
front of the brains is the forehead
right behind here this is the back of
the head right here and and this is the
part that we really value this is the
cerebral cortex that you can see on the
on the top and this is the really the
part of the brain that that that makes
your whole body work there's parts of
the brain that allow you to control your
arms and your legs and your muscles
there's parts of the brain particularly
in the front that help you to decide
what to do today and what to do tomorrow
that allow you to to think and we know
that there's lots of things that we use
our brains for we're all using them now
we use our brains to learn about the
world this is a group of public school
teachers who came into my laboratory a
couple of years ago to learn some about
the things I'm going to tell you today
and you can see that they're all focused
on learning from cheeky who's a mess
student who's who's showing them his
particular experiment down here and
people have all different ways of
learning you can see some are really
intensely learning and some are sort of
learning on the periphery but but but
we're all using our brains to learn
about the world in different in
different ways we use our brains to
interact with people and materials this
is my son Alex and my niece Ruby and we
use our brains to help each other by
activating muscles to hold Ruby off the
ground here for example and and we use
our brains to predict the future and
that's what my son zach is doing I think
in this in this picture here so when we
have diseases of the brain there's a lot
of interest in trying to cure them or to
restore function and biomedical
engineers have been very very heavily
involved in this one way they do it is
by designing systems that let you look
inside the body without using a knife or
a scalpel to open it up in the old days
if you wanted to see what was happening
inside the brain the only way to do that
was to open up the brain and look inside
and obviously that's that's that's a
challenge but this is a picture from a
technique called magnetic resonance
imaging where you can see in quite a lot
of detail that brain that I showed you a
cartoon of before here's the forehead
here's the brain here's the back of the
brain the cerebellum the spinal cord and
you can see those regions of the
cerebral cortex that I talked about
earlier sometimes special regions of the
brain fail in Parkinson's disease
there's a set of cells that are deep
inside your brain that stop functioning
in the normal way and you're not able to
control muscle movements in the way that
you did before so Parkinson's patients
that have Parkinson's disease often have
tremors they can't control their motor
movements they have trouble initiating
movements and biomedical engineers not
completely understanding how this worked
designed systems that are that are
little electronic patches or little
electronic devices that are implanted
inside the body and this is sending
signals which are carried in a wire up
into the brain
and these little electrodes are
stimulating the brain and they discover
that if you stimulated the brain in the
right fashion you could allow patients
that have Parkinson's disease whose
brains aren't controlling motion in the
right way to control movements better
this is called deep brain stimulation
and now there are many millions of
people who have these devices who are
able to do the kinds of things I was
just talking about with the help of a
electronic mechanical device and and
surgeons use tools of biomedical
engineering all the time to try to
understand better how to treat patients
this is an electrical device a large
grid of electrodes which placed on the
brain of a patient that has epilepsy
allowing the physicians to find where in
the brain in a patient with epilepsy
these unusual electrical signals that
are creating seizures occur and then
once they find where they occur they can
they can treat disease so there's lots
of examples of Engineers people who
build things devices you can make images
with devices that you can implant
devices that can record how they're
helping doctors to improve treatment of
disease this this young gentleman has a
problem which would you what is it he
has a headache you know we all know when
we have somebody has a headache because
bolts of lightning shoot out of their
head how what do you do if you have a
headache you take some kind of medicine
right and how do you how do you get it
into your brain that's where the problem
is right you've got to you've got an
ache in your head and that and that egg
egg that pain is originating your brain
but how does the medicine get there so I
heard something
through the sorry through the blood and
how did it get into the blood you're
right on so you swallowed the pill and
just like oh you know yeah you you you
you swallow the pill it goes into your
stomach and your digestive system your
digestive system is specialized in
breaking things down into their chemical
components and then those smaller pieces
like the medicine get absorbed into your
bloodstream and the medicine goes all
over your body and some of it goes into
the brain but it goes everywhere right
the medicine goes everywhere and what
you hope is that some fraction of that
medicine gets into your brain and you
get rid of your headache but you know
there's also medicine going to your
liver and your kidneys and your skin and
your intestines it's going everywhere
right and why can we why can we treat
headaches with drugs like advil or
aspirin because the advil or the aspirin
molecules don't do anything or don't do
very much in the rest of our body right
they treat the headache and they don't
cause any bad effects but sometimes they
do right if you take too much aspirin
you can hurt your hearing you'll start
hearing ringing in your ears and if you
keep taking more aspirin you might even
start to lose your hearing if you take
too much advil you can damage your liver
right and so you have to be very careful
with how you take medicine and we're
wasting a lot of medicine right because
what you really want to do is focus it
here and and and and the rest of our
body that's getting this medicine isn't
really able to use it so it's not a
problem with headaches right because we
have good drugs you can take that are
really safe it's really hard to damage
your liver so you don't need to worry
about that that is a potential problem
but but most of us won't encounter it
right because the drugs that work don't
cause damage in other places and the way
that drugs get there is because they go
into the blood and the brain if I
inside the brain is filled with blood
vessels right this is that this is a
brain where all the brain is removed
except for the blood vessels which are
filled with red plastic die and you can
see that that the brain really is is a
ball like a tumbleweed of blood vessels
and we need to have all this blood and
all these blood vessels in our brain
because our brains are using chemicals
that are in the blood in order to do all
these things that we like for our brains
to do the brain is really special though
and the blood best one reason it is is
because the blood vessels in our brain
are very special that they they don't
allow just any chemical to go from the
blood into the brain right all this
blood is moving through your brain all
the time and the molecules are contained
within blood vessels or tubes which are
little highways that carry it all over
the brain and most of the drugs stay
inside the tubes most molecules stay
inside the tubes only a few drug
molecules are able to leak out of the
blood capillaries and reach the real
working cells of the brain the neurons
only if only only a small set of
compounds are able to do this aspirin
tylenol advil ibuprofen that's one kind
of molecule caffeine is another kind of
a molecule that if you drink it it gets
into your blood and it gets very readily
out of the blood vessels and into your
into your brain and and many of us take
advantage of that every morning when we
drink coffee you feel a little different
after you drink coffee than you did
before and that's because the caffeine
molecules have gotten out of the blood
vessels and into the brain most drug
molecules don't yeah so alcohol I wasn't
going to mention it but alcohol is one
of the best alcohol do you know what
what what the molecule that makes
alcohol work is its ethanol it's which
is which is a special kind of alcohol
alcohol ethanol is able to move very
rapidly from the blood into the brain
and that's why alcohol has effects on
the brain
you if you ingest alcohol you start to
feel different you start to behave
differently and it has that effect very
potent Lee because it gets out of the
brain now how does alcohol have that
effect nobody really knows what it is
that alcohol does when it gets into the
brain I think that was the question that
you're asking it does lots of things
most of them harmful it has this effect
on mood and behavior at particularly if
it's used chronically it can have very
bad effects on the brain so I didn't
answer your question perfectly and I'm
sorry but but it's a really good
question and a hard one to answer so
most drugs don't go through as easily as
alcohol does and so and so the problem
with that is that lets say that there's
a very serious disease somewhere in the
brain here like like God for a bit of a
tumor in the brain what you'd like to do
is is give drugs and you'd like those
drugs to accumulate in the brain but
most drug molecules don't they circulate
in the body and very few of them get out
into the into the brain where the tumor
cells are and so they can't kill the
tumor you know if you're unfortunate if
you know unfortunate people who've had
tumors in the brain like like like I do
you'll know that they do get
chemotherapy drugs and the problem with
giving them chemotherapy drugs is that
they're given by pills or they're given
by injections and they circulate in the
blood the way you describe and a few of
those molecules get in the brain but
most of them go somewhere else and so
what happens to patients that are taking
chemotherapy drugs they get very bad
side effects right what kind of side
effects do they get that you their hair
falls out and the hair falls out because
the drug is going to the skin where it
shouldn't be and it's killing cells that
are responsible for making hair in the
follicles of the skin they often get
very bad intestinal systems because it
hurts the lining of their stomach which
is also which is also always renewing
itself right so you and it hurts the
bone marrow so they get diseases of the
blood
so years ago we thought maybe there's a
different way to treat to treat diseases
like brain tumors which are
life-threatening and very serious and
difficult to treat with all the ordinary
ways that we give medicines and so we
developed these little wafers and you
can see it here it's about the size of a
dime this wafer is about the size of a
dime and it's made of a polymer and you
all know what polymers are now because
you visited Senya outside and seniya
showed you how to make a polymer called
nylon this is my son Zach making nylon
in the same way that you did on the
bench outside and nylon is a polymer
it's a very high molecular weight
synthetic chemical that that can be
formed by chemical reactions in a beaker
like you did outside and it has the
property that you can make it into a
material and in this case Zach like you
did with Sonya is made of fiber of nylon
now you can make amazing things out of
nylon and other polymers as you know
because it has really interesting
properties as a material in fact you
could mold nylon into a device like this
and you could make a very nice coin or a
wafer out of nylon that would be hard it
would be very difficult to break and and
you could you could make things like
that from it of course you can make
clothing from nylon and so and so you
can weave the threads like this into
fabrics now we knew that you could make
polymers like this but we wanted to make
polymers that were special in another
way that when you put them in the body
they'll slowly dissolve if I made a
wafer out of nylon and implanted that
nylon into the body it would stay there
wouldn't change at all forever basically
and and that's not necessarily what we
wanted to do we wanted instead to make a
wafer that would have good mechanical
properties so you could pick it up with
forceps and you could implant it into
tissues but that but that it would
slowly dissolve in water right that's
not a property one in nylon because you
don't want your nylon jacket to dissolve
when you're out in the rain
but but we did want that to happen in in
these wafers and in fact we wanted them
to dissolve in a very controlled way so
when you implant this wafer into a
tissue like into the brain it would
slowly slowly dissolve and the nylon if
you looked at this nylon is hard to tell
in a fiber but it's it's relatively
transparent and if you dried it out
completely it would look quite
transparent you can see that this
special polymer we made here is white
not transparent and it's white because
we synthesized it around a bunch of drug
molecules and the drug molecules are
white and so this wafer is filled with
drugs right so it's a plastic or polymer
wafer that will slowly degrade when you
put it in water or you put it in the
body which is largely water and it's
filled with drugs and so what happens if
you drop this into a test tube full of
water what the graph shows here is the
drug releasing from the wafer into the
water over time over a period of a
couple of weeks right all we did was
drop this wafer which was loaded with
drugs into a test tube full of water and
then we sampled the water every once in
a while and asked how many drug
molecules have come out of the wafer and
into the into the into the water and
what you see is molecules the drug
molecules are slowly slowly slowly
released from this wafer over a period
of about two weeks and then over the
next month the way for itself dissolves
and disappears so you're left with
nothing solid any longer so what could
you use this for in medicine I've
already given you hints about this right
if you could make a wafer like this that
slowly released drugs and disappeared
maybe you could use that to treat
diseases maybe you could use it to treat
serious diseases like brain tumors so
here's one of those magnetic resonance
imaging pictures of the brain I'm
joining from a different angle this time
this is like a cut this way so you're
looking at the brain from the top and
you can see inside here there's a region
that doesn't look like it should and
this is a this is a brain tumor so what
do surgeons do once they've identified
we're a tumor is they all try to
surgically remove it so do a surgery to
remove the tumor why does this work
because cancer our art is formed tumors
are formed from clusters of cells that
are growing out of control right cells
are dividing producing more sales more
cells and if you could remove the cells
that are causing the cancer maybe you
can get rid of the disease and so
surgeons have been doing this for many
many years and it it it helps but it
doesn't help enough and that most
patients who have the most serious form
of brain tumors if you take out the
tumor it will after some period of time
reappear so most patients who have the
most serious forms of brain tumors don't
live for a year or two years they die
within a few months even after you move
this tumor so we thought what if we gave
these to these these wafers to surgeons
as a tool they're going to remove the
tumor but when they remove the tumor
they could put back into the space where
the tumor was they could put these
wafers into the tumor and this is a this
is a picture from the operating room of
my friend Henry Bram who's the chair of
neurosurgery at Johns Hopkins and he
really pioneered this technique of
taking the wafers that we made in
laboratory and placing them into the
into the place where the tumor used to
be and what's the advantage of that now
you don't have most of the tumor cells
anymore and the patient leaves the
operating room with these devices that
are slowly releasing drugs the drugs are
in the brain they're not in the rest of
the body so the drug is right where the
tumor is hopefully they'll kill the
tumor cells more effectively and even
more importantly they won't go to the
rest of the body these molecules are now
trapped in the brain and so they won't
go to the skin and cause hair loss they
won't go to the bone marrow and cause
and cause at cause anemia they won't go
to the intestine and cause intestinal
disease this makes sense as a approach
so so how would you test if that worked
we tested it in animals these are rats
that have
tumors and what these curves show you is
is this is this these are animals
surviving as a function of time so
animals who have brain tumors this kind
of brain tumor they don't live for very
long from when their tumor starts two
weeks most of the animals are not
surviving anymore right but if you but
if you give them one of these treatments
by implanting a polymer that contains a
drug called bc on you in the brain they
live much longer the average they live
six to seven weeks and some of these
animals are cured of their tumors they
you never see the tumor coming back and
and you have to test it in animals
before you test it in people because you
want to make sure that you've done the
engineering right so that the thing that
you're implanting at people is
completely safe and that's why we did
all these studies but eventually it was
tested in human patients that have
tumors and what do you see here this
these are patients who go to the
operating room to have their tumors
removed and when they get the tumor
removed they either get a polymer that
didn't contain any drug or they get a
polymer wafer that contain the drug bcnu
and the patients that were lucky enough
to get the polymer that had the drug and
it lived longer and some of them live
much longer than you would expect based
on this very serious disease so I
realized I was explaining a lot of
things here with with graphs but what do
you think of this result on the one hand
we were very happy because this this
turned out to be this was approved by
the FDA in 1996 and has become available
for patients all over the world but big
and that's because we we shifted this
survival curve so that patients are
living longer but they're not living
that much longer all right so we made
something new and it worked and it
helped people but we haven't totally
addressed the problem right because
because patients still don't live very
long with this serious disease so I was
very proud of this it was the first new
treatment for brain tumors in 25 years
that have been approved by the FDA was
it was an advance in brain tumor
treatment but it's not where we would
like to be we would like this blue curve
to be way out here right so we thought a
lot about why it worked and why it
didn't work and so this is a this is a
question I have for you if you if you if
you if you put a drug releasing implant
like this in the brain what do you think
happens to the drug molecules we learned
about what happens to drug molecules
when they go into the blood they
circulate and then they go into tissues
all over the body but what happens when
you put them into this in this special
way into the brain and so what do they
here's one answer do drug molecules
accumulate too high concentrations in
brain tissue well that's what we hoped
would happen that the drug molecules
would accumulate too high concentrations
do they spread from the implant to cover
the entire brain that makes sense right
the implants in there for a long time
and so drug molecule should go all over
the brain and they should cover the
brain so we ought to be able to treat
kill tumor cells that are anywhere
inside the brain in this approach do
they move out of the brain and cause
toxicity in the bone marrow no because
they're in the brain so they can't get
out very easily and there and then they
never make it to the bone marrow so it
turns out that the answer to this is two
of the above two of these things are
true and one isn't which one isn't true
see now see turns out to be true turns
out to be true when you when you put the
drug into the brain in this special way
you get almost no side effects outside
of the brain so we've almost completely
eliminated the normal kinds of side
effects that you have with chemotherapy
so C is true of a and B which one isn't
true
hey no it turns out that one's true that
they do accumulate too high
concentrations and that's why it works
because you get very high concentrations
what they don't do is spread out from
the implant to cover the entire brain
and instead when you put when you put an
implant in the brain like this and this
is a special measurement which I won't
describe completely but here's an
implant that we put in the brain and
then we can and then we can track where
the drug molecules go and so the drug
molecules are released and you get very
high concentrations of drug right around
the implant very high concentrations
higher than anyone's ever measured in
the brain and that's why they're
effective but they don't go very far if
you look only a millimeter or two a very
small distance away from the implant you
find no drug molecules all of the drug
molecules stay inside and and those of
you who have good intuition in physics
will understand this what we what we're
pretty sure now happens is that drug
molecules are released in the brain and
they begin to diffuse they begin to move
away but remember these are chemotherapy
drugs they're highly reactive they're
killing cells or they're being degraded
by our normal metabolism and so by the
time the molecule has moved from here to
here it's all used up right and none of
it can get this far so we do a very good
job of treating cancer when it's very
close to the implant but when there's a
tumor cell that's this far away it
doesn't even know that the drug is there
and so these cells can start growing
again and form a new tumors so so how
are we going to get this drug molecule
these drug molecules which are very
effective at the place where you've put
them how are we going to get them to go
through the brain well this this is one
way to do it and and I like this idea
and you can tell me if you think it's
going to work but instead of making a
big way for the size of a dime what if
we what if we shrunk it down so instead
of making a big wafer we made tiny tiny
particles and that's what these are
these are tiny tiny particles that have
all the properties that I showed that I
described for you before they're made of
polymers
they dissolve slowly in water they
contain a lot of drug but they're very
very small in fact this scale bar is 500
nanometers or a half of a micron a
micron is how big a bacterium is you
can't see it you can't see bacteria
right they're small these are these are
much much smaller than that in fact
they're the size of a virus a virus that
causes causes a cold they're the same
size but they're totally synthetic
they're made of polymers they're packed
with drugs and if you put them into the
body they'll release the drug in the
same way I showed you before and then
they'll slowly dissolve and the way that
we imagine getting these into the brain
is by infusing them so here's the
treatment that we that we currently have
we're a surgeon implants the polymer and
you get a zone of drug the drug is shown
as red here right around where the
polymer is so these are very very good
at treating tumors that are right there
by the implant but if we could break
this down into a billion pieces and then
infuse them in the brain in a way that
each piece is able to penetrate out into
the brain the surgeon could instead of
implanting this device he could put a
needle or a catheter into the brain he
could infuse our tiny particles the tiny
particles would crawl out into all
reaches of the brain and once they were
there they would sit in these locations
and release their drugs in the same slow
way I described before and they would
kill all the tumor cells that are in the
vicinity of this small particle have the
same advantage in not causing side
effects but but a big advantage in terms
of penetrating is so we're very
optimistic about this new technique when
we've tested it in animals Andy Sawyer
and his wife Jenny did these experiments
and show that they could that they could
get much better treatment of brain
tumors and animals using this new
approach where we make tiny tiny
particles and infuse them all through
the brain in fact thirty percent of the
animals are completely cured of brain
cancer in this particular experiment and
we're working with physicians at at the
Yale New Haven Hospital to try to to try
to bring this
therapy to patients within the within
the hopefully within the next few years
now that's good for brain tumors but how
would you treat tumors in other places
you need to make these tiny particles
smart somehow right in in that example I
just showed you the particles didn't
need to be very smart because the
surgeon was smart he knew where to put
them into the brain right but what if
you could make a particle that was as
smart as a surgeon so that you injected
into the body you injected into the
blood it goes all over the body and it
finds the tumor right that's what we're
working on next and we have some and we
have some some particles that appear to
work that way these particles are red
and this is a this is a mouse and we
injected it into the into the tail vein
of a mouse so it circulates all through
the body and this is a mouse that has
unfortunately has a tumor you can't see
it yet but now you see the tumor right
there where's all the red particles
mainly in the tumor right so you can
make these particles that you can inject
into the body they're very small they
circulate very easily and they're smart
enough to know where the tumor is and
when they find the tumor they stay there
and we're hoping that this could be a
new way to treat cancers that appear any
way any place in the in the body this is
work from a medical oncologist anow use
in treating prostate and ovarian cancer
I want to change directions a little bit
and talk up these are so that these are
this is a new way that medicines are
going to be delivered it's maybe not so
new because some of these things I've
described are now being used to treat
cancer all over the world but but i
think these ideas are going to become
more widespread in areas other areas of
treating diseases as well and that's why
I call it medicines of the future this
next part is a little bit more
futuristic and it involves not just
using drugs but using naturally
occurring
molecules that our body makes in order
to in order to build itself really so
what I listed here are two proteins that
are growth factors vascular endothelial
growth factor this is a molecule that's
made naturally in your body all the time
and it's one of its jobs in your body is
to promote the growth of new blood
vessels in regions of your body that's
not getting enough oxygen this molecule
gets released and new blood vessels grow
so where might be a place in your body
where you need new blood vessels in
adults mainly we have blood vessels
everywhere we don't need new ones all
the time but there's some diseases you
get where you need new blood vessels to
be recreated you think about what
diseases that might be yeah in the heart
right leading cause of death in the in
the united states is heart disease and
most of heart disease is because there
are blood vessels in your heart that
stopped working right and they're not
carrying oxygen to the heart tissue in
the right way but if you could deliver
vascular growth factor there you might
encourage the heart to grow new blood
vessels I think that's exactly right so
that's the example I want to talk about
nerve growth factor is another kind of
molecule that your body makes naturally
and what it does is promote the survival
and maturation of certain kinds of
neurons so your body particularly in
your brain is making nerve growth factor
all the time and this molecule helps
your neurons to live healthy lives and
to stay in your brain and keep doing
what they're supposed to do in some
cases though that doesn't happen and so
you knit you you'd like to be able to
promote survival and I talked about one
example of that in Parkinson's disease
another example where cells are not
surviving and they should is El timers
disease right cells in your brain are
slowly dying and you're losing function
because of that so you already know how
to make how to make how to make delivery
systems for proteins because Jill showed
you how to do it on the bench outside
this is that same experiment or
demonstration that she showed you these
are tiny particles
you make by a very simple method of
taking alginate a polymer that's a
naturally-occurring polymer of a
polysaccharide and dropping it into a
bath of calcium and and the calcium
causes the polymers to all linked
together and so they form tiny particles
and you can see those particles because
Jill showed you how to make them with
food coloring in them so that they
appear in different colors but you can
also make them with with growth factors
like like like vascular endothelial
growth factor this molecule in them and
it turns out this is a better way to
make factors like this because these
proteins are very sensitive if you made
them in the kinds of using the kinds of
approaches that Senya showed you where
you synthesize polymers in organic
solvents you these things would not
survive these drugs are much more
sensitive so you need gentle methods
like this one in order to make particles
but you could use these particles in the
same way that I described before in fact
if you take a bunch of these particles
and you inject it into a into the skin
they release the molecule and they make
new blood vessels form in the skin and
here you can see a new blood vessel that
we produced in a mouse just by injecting
a few of those particles that contain
vascular endothelial growth factor into
the mouse and here we could measure how
many and we design systems that cause a
lot of blood vessels to grow locally so
what would you do with this well what if
instead of what if instead of doing
surgery bypass surgery to add new blood
vessels to the surface of the heart when
you found out that a heart with starting
to lose its blood vessels or become
unhealthy you could just inject some of
these particles right on the surface of
the heart and cause new blood vessels to
form delivering more oxygen to the
tissue so we think that this is a that
this this might someday if we keep
working on it be a valuable approach for
treating certain kinds of diseases i
mentioned i'm going to give one last
example and then then i'll hopefully
leave time for some questions but i
mentioned i mentioned parkinson's
disease
and I mentioned ways of treating
Parkinson's disease there at the very
beginning with a deep brain stimulator
and and that's been a tremendous advance
for patients but but it doesn't treat
the underlying disease what's really
happening in the brain of patients that
have Parkinson's disease is that the
neurons that are responsible for helping
you control your motor system are
starting to die and those neurons are
shown in this picture of the brain in a
normal brain you can see lots of those
neurons there the brown cells here and
in someone that has Parkinson's disease
you find many fewer of them and it's the
loss of those neurons in your brain
that's causing the disease the brain
these these cells have a pigment which
is what makes them brown and so if you
look this is really in the brain you can
see here's the region where those cells
are and those cells are disappearing so
what if you could encourage one
discourage those cells from dying and to
put new cells back in this area of the
brain where where it's depleted one way
to do that is by using these kinds of
systems I described before but using it
in a different way and i'm going to show
you i'm going to show you the end result
but this is a this is a cluster of brain
cells that we've that we've that we've
manipulated outside the body so this is
many thousands of brain cells the kinds
of brain cells that are lost in
Parkinson's disease that we've
maintained outside the body in a way
that they form a little cluster of
tissue and what you can't see here is
that this little cluster of tissue is
all held together with tiny polymer
microparticles like the ones I've been
describing before so if you could look
inside this the micro particles are
green the cells are red for example you
can see these little particles inside
and these particles are not only holding
the brain cells together they're also
releasing this molecule called nerve
growth factor which helps cells survive
in the brain and keeps them in their
mature state so here we've made a little
piece of tissue which we think might
resemble
well some of the some aspects of the
tissue that's lost in Parkinson's
disease we've made it outside the body
using exactly these same kinds of
methods I told you before are used for
making drug delivery systems now if you
put this back into the body what happens
is the nerve growth factor comes out of
the tiny particles it accumulates in the
brain it comes to very high
concentration and it helps those cells
survive in the brain for a much longer
time than they would if we just put the
cells in on their own now this is this
is a much more in the distant future
kind of treatment but we think someday
it might be possible to combine these
kinds of materials I talked about before
with cells that are transplanted just
like our brain tumor implants are
implanted in the brain but these are
transplanted back into regions of the
brain that need new cells and could help
people recover from diseases like
Parkinson's disease and Alzheimer's
disease the question you would ask is
where do the cells come from and that's
it that's a challenge for the future but
there are places around the world like
Yale where biologists are working in in
on in in centers like Yale's stem cell
center to try to learn how to produce
these kinds of cells in ways that can be
that can be to produce cells like these
brain cells that can be transplanted
back safely into people so we think in
terms of the curve in terms of
engineering here and that we have to
wait for the biology of identifying the
right stem cells to catch up with us
just one last slide to show you some
people i've mentioned people as we've
come along and you met Jill and seniya
who are both doing research in this in
this field and I just show you some
pictures of Yale undergraduates and
we've had high school students who come
into the laboratory to work on these
projects with us and one of the great
pleasures for me is not only being a
scientist but be able to work with very
smart very talented very highly
motivated people to try to
make these kinds of visions for the
future a reality thanks for your
attention I think I've left a little bit
of time for questions if you have